so you obviously lost this seat at the
election
you were the mp previously yeah why do
you think you lost it
i think there were a number of reasons
but the main one to be honest with you
was was definitely brexit
and it was something that i'd been
concerned about for a very long time
and and i've been pushing and pushing
regarding what i was feeling what i was
hearing um
with regards to brexit and it proved to
be right
because this was a lead voting seat and
i guess later were promising a
second referendum and do you think it
was a mistake i think we're in a very
difficult position
in the party and laura was rightly
warning
everybody when we were going through
that period within the party and trying
to determine what we were going to do
ultimately we were trying to bring
back to together divided communities
those who voted leave and those who
voted remain
but certainly in my own constituency and
in laura's
when we were knocking on doors many of
our lead voters they didn't realize that
we were trying to stop a damaging brexit
and that we were trying to get a deal
and then put it to a public vote they
just saw us trying to overturn
the democratic mandate that they've
given us um so who are you going to be
backing then in the in the race to be
the next leader
for reasons like with regards to um
policies like the green industrial
revolution i will be backing becky
because i think she's proven that she
can develop policies
and she has that vision what we've got
to do now as a party is just
make sure that that is getting to voters
and that's where we have we've struggled
and we haven't managed to do that
just finally there's a picture of you
went viral
this week um at the job center i mean
it's quite a brutal
reality i guess on what life is like for
many people after
you lose the election yeah i mean i was
the thing is with me i was never lying
when i said that i was a working class
member of this community and i'm out of
work
so i'll do the same thing that everybody
does when they're out of work i'll look
at all of my options i've got two
children to look after
two elderly parents to look after as
well and
i need to have all of those options um
available to me
and i think it's more why i'm quite
pleased that it's happened actually
is we need to deal with the
misconception that everybody who enters
politics
has loads of money behind them loads of
connections because certainly within the
labour party that just isn't true we do
have and we lost
a lot of good working-class people who
were
embedded in their constituencies just
like i was and
yeah it's it's no shock really that
surprise surprise you're out of work
you're just like everybody else
so why do you think that labour lost the
election i think there was a variety
of reasons it was one of the worst
election defeats we've ever faced and
people say that it was brexit election
and brexit was a huge factor it
certainly came up on the doorstep in my
constituency
and indeed here where we lost the
fantastic laura smith
as our mp however there are a number of
other issues our manifesto
was not being sold on the doorstep the
messages
that should have gone through about
economic competence the fact that we
were going to
roll out a green industrial revolution
and kick-start the economy in regions
and nations across the uk
simply wasn't resonating with people and
certainly the ground campaign itself
we had reports of members being sent to
seats that we had no hope of winning
when we should have been in
constituencies trying to protect mps who
were
at risk of losing their seats at the
same time though it can't just be
selling
the policies that's the issue is it the
policies themselves
not at all and and certainly i mean
there were a number of areas where
we hadn't done enough work in convincing
voters of our credibility on those areas
there were certainly other policies that
were part of a longer term program they
were the right
answers to the right questions but
perhaps for a manifesto
they should have been left for a longer
term goal and
it led to the situation where many
voters felt that they were being
peppered with policies
and however the platform upon which many
of those policies were developed was a
positive one and
as i said it did deal with the
reinvestment and reinvigoration
of our economy and the shift of wealth
and power away from
those you know few minorities that have
it to everybody in every single
community
but we didn't get that message through
unfortunately we need to recognize that
and recognize why we failed and that's
why it's important to have listening
exercises
in the constituencies where we lost to
find out why people didn't trust us
quite frankly you say that
labour had the right answer to the right
questions does that mean you think
labour won the argument
not at all we didn't win the argument if
we won the argument we'd have won the
general election unfortunately and we
didn't
we just weren't trusted and and that
goes for the message that we put out in
our campaign which didn't bring together
all of the positive aspects of our
manifesto we weren't trusted on brexit
we weren't trusted to deal with
anti-semitism within our own party key
issues and you have to earn trust it
doesn't just happen
overnight unfortunately trust and
policies are linked as well aren't they
i mean people didn't trust the policies
because they thought they were
unrealistic
they did i mean for example i mean one
example i'll give you is broadband and
there was a clear argument that could
have been made for broadband
about how bringing broadband into public
ownership would speed up the rollout of
broadband which would improve
productivity because more businesses
would be connected to that high-speed
broadband
however we weren't given the opportunity
all the time to make that argument in
such a small
space of time within the general
election it's interesting listening to
you though because
you're almost saying that the policies
were the right ones but they weren't
sold in the right way or you didn't have
the arguments necessary to convince
people that they were right
this is your worst reelection result
since 1935 when you lost seats like
don valley blind valley they've always
been labour
it's almost like you're arguing that you
should you know take a dustbin and brush
to an earthquake site
i think we've also got to recognize that
the decline of our support in these
seats hasn't happened overnight
it has been happening over a period of
time certainly over the last 10 years
but i would go
as far back as 1979 where our economic
model changed
and we saw the deindustrialization of
areas right across the uk and in our
regions and nations and many of our
communities haven't recovered from that
and they bear the scars of that and what
we needed to see in this general
election was the labour party going out
there and showing how we were going to
solve that problem
rebalance and reinvest in our economy
and build a world
after brexit and we didn't get that
message through
um you wrote in an article this week in
tribune and i don't disagree with the
policies i've spent the last four years
writing them so are you the continuity
corbin candidate
not at all not at all it annoys me when
people say that and unfortunately as a
woman it annoys me even more
and i'm a person in my own right i was
very proud
of the green industrial revolution our
green new deal i spent nearly four years
developing
with members with their trade unionists
with green groups
to make sure that we had policies
developed from the ground up
and that provided a lot of answers um in
terms of both what we need to do to
tackle the climate emergency
but also what we need to do to
kick-start our economy and invest in
areas that needed to see
new high-paid high-skilled jobs and that
would
have provided a catalyst for that and
it's sad that we didn't push that in our
general election campaign
and we didn't make sure that that was
part of the key messaging that went out
to our communities
so if you uh say that you're not the
continuity corbin candidate would you
describe yourself as a carbonite
i would describe myself as a socialist
and i supported
jeremy from the start because he
believed in many of the same things that
i did as many of people
within our party do and indeed many of
our mps do and
and what we need to do now is stop
labeling ourselves as carbonites as
socialists or whatever we are in the
labour party
we are all socialists within the labour
party we need to unite
we need to build a program that can win
and we need to take our communities
to the to the state that they should be
in where they're invested in where the
quality of life
is the highest law in every single
community okay i'm quite keen to get a
bit of a picture about the kind of
policies that you would pursue
if you do end up winning the leadership
election one part of course that did end
up having a very good election
result was the snp so if you were a
leader would you ever grant a second
independence referendum i'm fully
committed to the union
um and i don't think that should be
shaken in any way
but ultimately the people of scotland
need to make the case and they've got
their own parliament to determine
whether they want to push that and that
will be for
me as a prime minister to to to review
and to look at and i wouldn't want to
inhibit the democracy
of people because that's one of the most
fundamental pillars
that we're proud of in this country
quite frankly but no i don't
um you know support in any way the
breaking
up of scotland but you could grant you
could grant a second referendum
i wouldn't be in favor of it i'm honest
and it's not something that i'll be
pushing for or arguing for i'll be
arguing to keep the union
and i think we need to work very hard as
a party to rebuild trust
in our scottish heartlands which have
been declining over time for a variety
of reasons but ultimately
people must feel that they have a
democratic voice
and on the house of lords as well so you
wrote this week that labour must go to
war with the political establishment
pledging a constitutional revolution
that sweeps away the house of lords does
that mean you want to abolish the house
of law that's right i do want to abolish
the house of lords and we'll be rolling
out as my campaign progresses
how we we intend to to really shake up
that constitutional
package because mps like myself and you
met laura
earlier on we're fed up of the
westminster bubble and we're fed up of
our communities feeling
like decisions about their lives are
made in westminster consistently
we've got to shift power and wealth into
our communities and that needs to be
done in a democratic and structured way
so how would you
find a system where there was a check on
the activities of the house of commons
because that is
historically the role of the house of
lords right there would need to be
checks and balances in place but to have
a set of completely unelected people
doing that i don't think is right and i
think many people within our communities
would not think that was right we need
to have people
who are able experts people who feel
that they're democratically accountable
to the communities that they represent
not people who were appointed by parties
then what do you make of the current
makeup of the house of lords then the
people who are in there
i don't know a lot about all the lords
if i'm honest individually
and we've got some fantastic now you
want to abolish that we've got to well
we've got some fantastic people of
course that you know have done fantastic
things for their communities but it's
not them as individuals that i'm
concerned about
is the fact that they're not
democratically accountable to anybody
and i don't think that
is the basis of good democracy okay now
the next leader of course
will have to deal with the allegations
of anti-semitism within the labour party
something that
we all know was brought up uh during the
election campaign by lots of voters
now this weekend the president of the
board of deputies of british jews has
said that the relationship between
labour
and the jewish community has been all
but destroyed
and she's outlining 10 pledges that she
wants all of the leadership candidates
to
sign up to things like making the
disciplinary process fully transparent
and independent will you sign up to
those i will
indeed straight away and i think we need
to work very hard and very robustly
whoever the leader becomes to repair our
relationship with the jewish community i
was absolutely devastated
as many of our members were to knock on
the doors of jewish
community members who said that they
just didn't trust the labour party
anymore
and we do need to work hard to rebuild
that trust but that requires
action it requires making sure that we
implement any recommendations that the
ehrc come back with and they're due to
report
shortly and it means adopting the
recommendations that the board of
deputies have put forward
if you were so devastated to hear the
message from
british jews what did you do personally
as a member of the shadow cabinet for
three years to try and tackle
anti-semitism and labor so i wasn't
happy with the way our process had been
when i'll be honest
i don't think we were dealing with um
complaints quickly enough and i think
that's quite clear i've been quite vocal
about that i also felt that there should
have been a level of independence
to the the the allegations the way they
were investigated and that's not just
for anti-semitism by the way that's in
terms of all
complaints racism um abuse and
you know sexual misconduct so what did
you do did you speak up did you have a
go at jeremy corbyn what did you do i
did i did i mean i spoke i spoke to
jeremy about
it i spoke to various members of the
team and i spoke to various members of
the nec
about that and what did they say well i
think everybody wanted to find the
answers there was nobody that i came
across that didn't want to tackle this
problem
but what we didn't do was help ourselves
to tackle it we didn't act quickly
enough
the messages that we were sending out to
the community were confusing
we weren't working hand in hand with the
jewish communal organizations in the way
that we should and responding to what
they were advising us to do
and that mistrust built rapidly over
time and
and we will need to act quickly to
remedy that and i hope that we do
whoever the leader is because
we need to to make sure that we are the
party that
has the gold standard on any form of
anti-semitism
racism and discrimination and that's why
we're all proud to be labour members
we've got to make sure that we have our
own house in order on this
emily thornbury was asked to rate jeremy
corbyn's dealing of anti-semitism she
gave it two out of ten
what would you give it i wouldn't give
anything a rating i mean it's not you
gave him a rating
well it's not it's not trump's it's too
serious to give ratings we didn't
tackle the issue it's as simple as that
we have lost trust and
within the jewish community they don't
believe that we're tackling
anti-semitism and talking about small
numbers of our members
being involved in it and saying that
it's not a big issue isn't good enough
because
if you don't tackle a problem you don't
have robust processes in place
and we haven't worked with jewish
communal organizations then we've not
done our job
did uh does jeremy corbyn bear personal
responsibility for him he does and he's
apologized and i think
any labour politician that leads the
labour party should apologize again for
what has happened
because it has been unacceptable now i
just want to talk a bit about your
campaign because many people at the
beginning
of the race thought that you were the
front-runner it seems that kirsten was
perhaps taking that mantle um i just
wonder if you think that your campaign's
got off to a bit of a rocky start i mean
you were the last person to declare
you had some quite negative reviews from
mps coming out of that and parliamentary
labour party meetings
once told the guardian that it was like
listening to someone that was like
watching paint dry
they're not a fan then obviously they're
oh they you can't win them all
can you are you a bit disappointed with
how things have gone so far
no i mean i wasn't ready to launch a
leadership campaign before christmas
because i was having a period of
reflection
i haven't been planning to become the
leader of the labour party as many
people know
i didn't have a campaign ready to go
because i was trying to win the general
election
and like many members and many
um you know activists right across the
country i was in a state of shock
at the devastation and we needed to to
have a look at what happened in our own
communities
and understand the reasons to why we had
such a shocking
defeat and over christmas i spent time
with my family
thinking about what was right for the
party what would be right for
my family and how i could drive forward
my principles within the party to make
sure that we could transform the
communities
in in the way that we should and i've
never been personally ambitious
and i got involved in politics because
of my principles and it's my principles
that drove me to stand to become leader
of the labour party because i'm proud
of fighting for the for the platform
where
we you know reinvest in our economy
where we protect the vulnerable
where we push a green industrial
revolution to tackle climate change
urgently
and we offer a vision of hope for the
future but not just a vision of hope
about aspiration and that's what our
whole movement is about it's about
everybody aspiring
to be the best that they possibly can be
whether you're a business or whether
you're an individual and somewhere along
the line in our campaign that message
never came through and that's certainly
what i'll be pushing it's interesting
you say there that you
aren't personally ambitious i know that
you've been encouraged to stand by lots
of people in your parties that you know
stand a bear
at the left if you like do you really
want it
of course i do i want to lead this party
and not only lead the party i want to be
prime minister because i got involved in
politics to change the world
i got involved in politics because i
knew that sitting from the sidelines in
a comfortable career
feeling good with myself because i'd
come from nothing and aspired to do very
very well and achieved
that wasn't going to make life better
for people around me that wasn't going
to mean that the people i grew up with
were going to have the same things that
i enjoyed in life
so that's why i wanted to get involved
in politics and i haven't finished doing
that job yet so that's why i'm going to
become prime minister
and just a couple of um quick questions
just to end um
your friend and flatmate angela rainey
was running for deputy did you kind of
come up with a pack to run together like
in the flat over a take away in a glass
of wine how did that happen
we always joked we always joke to be
honest the parables that you know
if it ever goes wrong you know it's
gonna be me and you're gonna have to
sort it out we're the only ones that are
gonna be able to do this you know
and then when it went wrong so i know
exactly and then
we had the the defeat and it was
devastating we both sat down and was
like you know
we're joking you know we actually are
gonna have to think about this because
obviously you know
everybody loves angela because she's
amazing and i was getting you know
contacted by various people and we were
getting encouraged
you know to do this so we wanted to make
sure that what we did was together
because we thought that together
as a joint ticket a leader and a deputy
because we're so close
we're close but slightly different you
know in terms of the way we operate and
the way we are
we thought we would be a really positive
unifying force
for the parliamentary labour party for
our membership
and also send a positive message out to
the country after
years of division quite frankly and
quite fractious politics that
politics does not have to be nasty
talking about um fractious
debates i've got to get your view on the
big debate at the moment
harry and megan where'd you stand how do
you make it about whether they leave the
uk or not
i don't want them to leave the uk but
i'll be honest i mean
megan you know she's talked about
hostility from you know all the kind of
sections of the press i mean certainly
one of the things i've witnessed in in
my
kind of early days of my campaign this
was even before i decided to stand as
leader
were the levels of abuse and the fact
that i was getting targeted above all
the other candidates for some reason
and and it seemed quite hostile and you
know i think she's faced
you know horrific abuse within the press
and that's not acceptable you know
sexism i think certainly you know
male counterparts don't receive the same
level of hostility
and i think the media has a job to make
sure that it is balanced
it is looking at the facts of course you
know report facts and attack where you
can see that there are misdemeanors
wrongdoings or inaccuracies
but don't attack a woman for the sake of
attacking a woman just finally
can you clear it up is there a hyphen in
long bay or not there's actually there
actually is a hyphen
but i'm not bothered i mean i'm i was
rebecca long before i got married
and i thought it was a really good idea
to keep the long because i was quite
proud we're all girls in our family so
there was no one to kind of carry on the
name
so um so i wanted to add the bailey on
not to upset the husband to make him
feel like he was part of it all
right so i'm not bothered if people put
a hyphen in or not it doesn't bother me
as long as the lungs there and the
bailey's there